speaking of vaccines uh there is
something very interesting going on
which is that donald trump the former
president
although he was softly dismissive
of
vaccination when it comes to any kind of
requirement and continued to play up
freedom we all need our freedom we all
need our freedom
has actually become
a very forceful advocate for the safety
and efficacy of covet vaccines
and we have an incredible clip from
yesterday donald trump did another
interview with oan so you've got fox
news which is crazy right wing
you've got newsmax which is even crazier
and then you've got oan which is even
crazier than newsmax and donald trump
was sort of softly confronted by the
reporter about there's all these people
concerned
there's all these concerns about the
vaccine
and donald trump very forcefully said
it's ridiculous and by the way listen to
when trump says there are uh officials
who are not even telling the truth that
they've been vaccinated i believe he is
signaling ron desantis here and i'm
going to get back to that let's check
out this clip
a lot of viewers wrote in i put a kind
of all call out to our viewers on the
program if you had questions for the
president what would it be top two
election integrity we'll get to in a
second but the other one was the vaccine
right you recently stated an interview
with candace owens and when you were on
the road with bill o'reilly doing uh the
book tour and the speaking engagement
that you've had the vaccine two shots
and you've had the booster right um and
you recommend it for folks
we have seen with the vares report
there's tens of thousands of side
effects now remember the vayer's reports
are unverified this is important anyone
can submit something to theirs anybody
the the their we can't glean anything
from vayers side effects in this vaccine
any vaccine history and more deaths dr
robert malone nine patents for the mrna
technology being used in the vaccines
remember robert malone's claims have
already been debunked he came on my
program weeks ago and said unless you're
over 65 and have a cold morbidity i
recommend it other than that i don't
recommend taking it he even
is upset he took it himself he's having
heart issues
looking back we know that warp speed was
great you did amazing with getting rid
of it
and and the talking out of both sides of
the mouth the rapidity with which you
got these vaccines done is amazing
we just don't want them because they're
not good vaccines getting them is great
using them nuts it's completely i mean
it is a pretzel it is a pretzel tape to
get something out there
but after now so many months of the
vaccine being administered and these
side effects and americans questions of
it do you reconsider your push for it or
what's your view now on the vaccine in
general well i've taken it i've had the
booster
many politicians i watched a couple of
politicians be interviewed
and one of the questions was did you get
the booster because they had the vaccine
and they oh they're answering it like in
other words the answer is yes but they
don't want to say it he's very clearly
referring to ron desantis there and this
is already a signal about if desantis
wants to be the nominee in 24 and trump
wants to be the nominee in 24 it's going
to get very ugly very quickly which i
love
because they're gutless you got to say
it
whether you had it or not say it
but the fact is that i think the vaccine
has saved
tens of millions of people throughout
the world
i have had absolutely no side effects
i've had it like other people have had
it nothing special
so donald trump here
is
he other than the fact that he takes
credit for the vaccines for which he
deserves no credit the the u.s
pre-purchased doses that's all they did
trump deserves no credit for the vaccine
these vaccines were going to be
developed in this amount of time no
matter who was president uh you could
have had uh you know barney rubble as
president these vaccines would have been
developed um
trump is absolutely right about what
he's saying and it is crazy that these
networks now are having to sort of play
put themselves in these pretzels
hilariously this guy on oan still
equates trump to jesus to see to just
look at the level of sycophancy now look
he's not perfect
no one is
he sins i sin we all sin
but as you know
who did our savior jesus christ hang out
with back in the day
who did he use to spread his message or
do his will right guess what they
weren't famous
they weren't politicians they weren't
rulers or tyrants
they were lepers
they were prostitutes they were the
blind and the deformed
the people that society had cast away
yeah they were in a word
deplorables right so there we go they
still love trump and see him as a
god-like figure
when trump is the voice of reason
you know you're on an insane network and
i without any hesitation trump's lying
about his role in the vaccines but what
trump is saying
about the vaccines themselves is
absolutely right
your internet traffic can be observed by
a number of people your internet service
provider big tech platforms even by the
government and that's why i protect my
internet connection with atlas vpn which
hides my ip address making me invisible
to these intermediaries on the internet
who can track me and sell my data i also
use atlas vpn to watch shows on netflix
and hulu only available in other
countries but the privacy aspect is
what's most important to me if you're
not using a vpn
read about it read about why they're so
important and with just one atlas vpn
account i can protect all of my devices
at the same time you turn it on once you
forget about it you stay anonymous right
now atlas vpn is having a big sale for
my audience giving you 86
off this comes out to a dollar 39 a
month plus you'll get three months free
just click the link below and use the
code pacman